[Musik]
los nein ich meine ob ich ihn hier
helfen kann ach so ja ähm ich muss
dringend ein bisschen
nicht auf wenn kannst da komme ich ja
lieber morgen früh um 5 Uhr auf ihrem
Bauernhof
haben Sie Interesse an einer Küche
jetzt kommen wir langsam was möchten Sie
denn für eine Ausstattung Induktionsherd
Mikrowelle Backofen
ja also eine Spüle ist ja immer mit drin
ja aber ich brauche größer die gibt es
auch in 60 cm zu klein 70 cm zu klein
ein Meter 80 Minimum was wofür brauchen
sie denn so eine riesige Spüle ja zum
100 Gold
aber so eine Küche ist doch kein Platz
mein Schwein zu schlachten es war aber
nicht nein gar nicht nein überhaupt
nicht nein ums verrecken nicht nein und
wenn man
das ist eine sehr sehr gute Idee gehen
Sie doch bitte in die badabteilung der
arbeitet ein sehr netter Kollege von mir
mein Ex-Mann der bereits
[Musik]
nein